une journée déterminante pour patrick
dils l'accusé du double meurtre de
montigny-lès-metz a d'abord clamé son
innocence
en préambule de son audition mais il a
eu bien du mal à s'expliquer sur
certains détails du dossier à lyon
clément weill raynal et sanaa graby
patrick 10 en difficulté cet après-midi
devant la cour d'assises du rhône
comment expliquer de manière
convaincante les aveux circonstanciés
qu'il avait passé il ya 15 ans devant
les policiers des aveux répétés au juge
d'instruction au psychologue et à ses
parents aujourd'hui il dit simplement
j'avais 16 ans j'avais peur j'étais pris
dans un engrenage je n'arrivais pas à
trouver les mots pour clamé mon
innocence
il explique dans quelle logique et dans
quel engrenage sur réaliste il sait
trouver pour passer des aveux de faits
abominables qui n'a jamais commis
et je vais je trouver ses explications
convaincantes comme j'ai trouvé les
interrogations de la présidente légitime
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
mécanisme intellectuel qui est
surprenant car quinze ans après de
lourdes charges paix est encore dans le
dossier face au juge d'instruction le
jeune garçon avait désigné sans
hésitation la pierre avec laquelle il
avait fracassé le crâne d'alexandre puis
celle avec laquelle ils avaient tué
cyril des aveux formulés alors que les
résultats du laboratoire de police
scientifique n'avait pas encore été
communiqué aux enquêteurs
quand patrick 10 désigne les pierres
ils correspondent exactement avec les
pierres frapper les enfants qui ont tué
les enfants et se sont tachées du sang
de chacun des enfants et qu'il le fait
spontanément sans hésitation
et sans attendre
et rapidement
seul
le coupable celui qui les a utilisés
celui qui a frappé les enfants
préférant tel talent désignation
manifestement patrick dils peine à
convaincre la cour d'assises
j'ai du mal à vous suivre conclut la
présidente après deux heures de
questions et de réponses vous aviez
tellement d'occasions de clamer votre
innocence
réponse de patrick glisse je suis
innocent ce que j'ai vécu personne ne
peut l'imaginer
personne ne peut les comprendre